[Musique]
on essaye d'avoir toujours un jeune avec
nous avec
[Musique]
et là aussi
de chez nous de chez nouveau qui a très
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a une élection présidentielle qui
nous attend une élection partir en
important pour plusieurs raisons tout
simplement pour mettre fin à cinq ans du
mandat d' emmanuel macron cinq ans de
promesses non tenues temps sur la
sécurité que sur les promesses
démocratiques
aujourd'hui les jeunes ont un véritable
pouvoir de faire changer les choses que
ce soit les jeunes qui ont l'habitude de
voter ou que ce soit les jeunes
abstentionnistes donc il faut se saisir
de ce droit là
non
ça s'est énervé salut c'est à dire peu
près mais bon on accepte emmanuel mâcon
quand même pas nous c'est pareil voilà
c'est par ce qui se fait très
régulièrement c'est qu'on échange
d'autres axes genre ça après le concours
j'aime pas ce terme là mais apple
bonjour républicain tu vois on n'est pas
d'accord mais h 30 on track tu prends
bien ça c'est pareil je le fais avec
tout le monde donc bon courage merci à
vous une bonne campagne merci aussi au
rendez vous du 24 avril absolument
là on est dans l'hyper centre de nantes
juste à côté du château des ducs de
bretagne j'habite ce juste derrière
quartier très sympa mais il s'avère que
iliad et on va dire des petits bastion
anti fasciste qui ne manque pas de me le
rappeler à chaque fois que j'ai
l'occasion de passer devant par un
sifflement une moquerie highmore
ici c'est particulièrement plus le coeur
de notre révolte est entrée noté qu'
second disque une extrême gauche qui
saccagent nantes tous les week-ends
ils vendent des goodies ils vendent des
autocollants appelant à la haine de
l'état la mort des policiers ils vivent
leur revue et ils ont sur deux camps sur
leurs réseaux sociaux des relais plus de
200000 personnes qui les suivent les ans
tu agis s'en cache pas le fait de
fréquenter ce bar là mais moi s'il est
ouvert il ya du monde devant si je passe
mieux que j'ai de l'endurance faut
courir parce que la cei est compliqué
[Musique]
non probablement suivie puisque ils ont
découvert ou est-ce que j'habitais que
je suis rentré chez moi un jour je suis
arrivée devant ma porte et m'apporter t
on va dire entrouverte légèrement
l'appartement était complètement
retourné sans dessus dessous ce n'était
pas un cambriolage mais c'était un
saccage gratuit la grande porte de mon
entrée taguée avec marquer clairement
dessus antifa claire keim au nom de
famille facho
[Musique]
un jour il vous disait qu'il était
socialiste l'autre jour il me disait
qu'il ne l'était pas c'est ça aussi le
véritable problème c'est que quand on
est une politique c'est qu'on ait une
vision des choses emmanuel macron il n'y
avait aucune vision pour la france et on
l'a bien vu depuis cinq ans que ça a
donné on a des scandales à répétition le
qu'il vienne me chercher c'est indigne
d'un président at-il dit j'emmerde les
français c'est indigne d'un président de
la république ce que vous voyez le
général de gaulle dire
[Musique]
à ce soir c'est un peu une occasion
particulière c'est la galette
traditionnelle des républicains on l'a
fait un peu tous les ans avec les jeunes
c'est aussi ça la politique la politique
c'est créer des liens et c'est créer du
sens donc si on n'a pas ces moments là à
quoi ça sert de s'engager là plus en
plus on rencontre de nouveaux visages
des personnes qui viennent de saint géry
parce qu'il ya une compagnie qui est en
cours enfin c'est le premier événement
tous voilà il faut pas les décevoir il
faut aller à leur rencontre il faut
aller discuter avec eux et leur montrer
que famille politique c'est justement
une vraie famille
[Musique]
j'étais autres canons bref encore m
c'était génial ils veulent faire croire
que je suis seul oh lola cette chair de
poule
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment eu du mal au début a
rejoint parce que je me disais que
j'étais peut-être un petit peu trop
jeune mais ce n'était pas forcément un
monde qui était fait pour moi et puis au
final al'approche de présidentielle
serré que j'ai voulu aider
à nous deux parties
et donc je me suis dit que c'était donc
le bon moment pour sauter le pas
outre la campagne de 2017 est
aujourd'hui et défaites nous ont fait du
mal beaucoup ont cru qu'on allait finir
par tomber qu'on allait sombrer mais
aujourd'hui on voit énormément de
militants qui reviennent et des nouveaux
en fait des très jeunes il n'ya pas
évidemment il ya eu quelques déçus qui
sont partis et quelques déçus que son
parti et qui sont venus mais on va dire
qu'il ya toujours ce sursaut que j'ai
connu au début avant les élections en
fait c'est aussi un éternel
recommencement